this just a text question here uh yeah
we had some other ones but i
i wanted to try to help uh some people
there were a couple reasons
some people is this from nick hey guys
seaman instead of [ __ ] please yes hey
guys i was curious what causes some guys
to see
me ejaculate like a firehouse and some
ejaculation faucet okay i've got some
little junk
but i can throw ropes across the room
right this this felt very love-lining
yeah it is very lovely so people are all
i hear even joe rogan making this
mistake the other day
he was people confuse where the
ejaculate fluid comes from
it has nothing to do with your testes
wow nothing that's new except except the
testosterone production
that the testes create sperm and
testosterone
sperm cells the fluid is created by your
prostate gland
wow and it is stored in the seminal
vesicles which are these
sort of looks like a wing almost under
the prostate of these these chambers
that store the fluid
and some people can produce a lot of
fluid and store a lot of fluid and
like mike can reproduce it very quickly
and they can put out and
big volumes and that's just a genetic
thing that just some people are that way
wow uh and so there's nothing you do to
enhance your
no that's well you can you could refrain
from
ejaculate does that help i heard it
helps use it or lose it to that point it
helps it helps a point yeah
it helps to a point but you can also go
the other way but people like me that
don't have a prostate
which produces the fluid mike ghost
loads
no fluids ghost loads there's nothing
nothing it's just like magic
one of those hairless cats one of those
hairless
sounds like a tom clancy novel i don't
like it i don't like harry potter
i need i need that i need that enzo
celebration
you know like i need to [ __ ] yeah
yeah yeah i want to
i want to end zone dance yeah just like
a windy day and that's it
uh there's even no wind it's just normal
is there a noise is it
i make the noise but that's it oh my god
but does anybody believe you if no semen
comes out does anybody believe yeah
you could fake it all the time you you
you first of all i think males are
motivated to fake you know what i mean
oh i know i've been there really
anything to get me out of the damn
bedroom dude i would do it
there's a lot packed into that statement
i feel like you guys might need a one on
one
but anyway so the point is the prostate
and the several vesicles where all the
fluid comes from
and into the seminal vesicles the the um
sperm just drips into the fluid to put
more sperm concentrations
oh wow like that budweiser plant like
you've ever been there
golden uh golden color of course yeah so
the the
the testes are just producing cells of
swimmers
that make their way up the vas deferens
and drip into the mix
now what about korean people and people
other people do they have the same thing
everybody has it the same does some
people have a thick
more you know dilute badge as you yes
there's differing
is as this questioner was asking there's
a whole range of volume
fluid you know thickness and there's
tapioca pudding there's all kinds of
stuff
can we help this guy and then go to your
story okay this one broke his dick yeah
this one was very lovely as well
hey theo brendan mike and drew i work
for fedex and have had some
something very strange happen to me i
pick up a lot of extremely heavy
packages during the day during the
lockdown numbers increased as well as
weight of the packages sometimes when
i'm picking up packages upwards of a
hundred pounds
you have to put your body weight into
throwing them onto shelves of the truck
well i had two very heavy packages catch
the edge of the shelf and the package
and the force of my body turning
into the package smashed my penis very
hard i have now developed peyronie's
disease from the drama
no i am with the love of my life but
this is emasculated and i'm worried she
will become frustrated and leave
and it's there and is there a way for
this to be fixed yeah i'd love to hear
dr
jude's response gang gang broke dick yes
yes you urologist there's a lot to be
done for peyronie's now
all kinds of stuff curable curable no
problem but if he he can affect if he
doesn't get it fixed it can affect his
ability to have an erection
it causes pain in your partner during
intercourse it's a mess and it can get
worse it's a it's a scar that forms on
one side of the penis that pulls it in
that direction so you get a big curve
the curve yeah it says acquired
peyronie's it is quite treatable go
ahead
what if my penis is kind of shaped like
a candy corn what is that i like that
which direction oh uh skinny part at the
top
that's better probably for wedging yeah
it's like a like
yeah it's like a auger yeah the king in
this game